parole du ps qui se prêtait à l'exercice
à
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne à la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi portant engagement national pour
l'environnement
la semaine dernière les sénateurs ont
achevé l'examen du titre 1 sur la
question des bâtiments et de l'urbanisme
depuis hier les examine un chapitre tout
aussi important de ce texte il s'agit de
la question des transports
car je vous rappelle qu'un des objectifs
du grenelle 2 et de prendre des mesures
en faveur des transports collectifs
urbains mais aussi péri urbain tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle bonne
matinée à tous sur public sénat l'ordre
du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi portant
engagement national pour l'environnement
nous sommes parvenus au titre 2 titres
de transport à l'article 16 nous avons
des demandes de parole de madame
mireille schürch monsieur michel teston
monsieur roland ries ce madame mireille
cherche vous avez la parole pour le
groupe crc spg
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'examen de ce projet de loi engagement
national pour l'environnement se déroule
continue de se dérouler d'ailleurs dans
des conditions difficiles qui ont déjà
été dénoncées par certains de mes
collègues je souhaite donc pour ma part
apporté mon appréciation générale sur ce
volet transport de ce projet de loi
certaines dispositions telles la
possibilité offerte à un syndicat mixte
compétent en matière de transports
publics d'adhérer à un syndicat mixte
sru et la modulation des péages nous
semble positive le travail en commission
nous a d'ailleurs permis d'exprimer
notre point de vue est d'introduire
quelques-uns de nos amendements
je pense notamment à la notion de
service régulier des transports à
l'amendement visant à limiter le
transfert obligatoire aux seuls
équipements situés sur les autres les
trottoirs adjacents aux voies empruntées
par les transports en site propre et à
la reconnaissance
de l'organisation de services de mise à
disposition des bicyclettes en libre
service
toutefois à ce stade je regrette que ce
projet de loi crée des contraintes
lourdes à la charge des collectivités
territoriales et des particuliers sans
préservation de la maîtrise publique en
termes d' expertise de conseil et de
contrôle laissant ses pans entiers à la
concurrence au des prix au détriment de
la préservation de l'intérêt général
de plus certains transferts de
compétences laisse penser à une mise en
oeuvre insidieuse de la réforme des
collectivités territoriales nous ne
souhaitons pas une réforme avant l'heure
et sommes favorables à l'intervention
publique en matière d'auto portage c'est
ce qui motive notamment nos amendements
au chapitre premier de ce titre
en ce qui concerne les dispositions sur
les investissements ferroviaires alors
qu'elles étaient détaillés dans la loi
de programmation
elles sont absentes curieusement absente
dans ce projet de loi et c'est hors
cadre parlementaire que monsieur le
ministre nous a présenté un grand
engagement national pour le fret
ferroviaire auquel il consacre 7
milliards en mars dernier lors de
l'examen du projet de loi autorités de
régulation des transports ferroviaires
j'avais proposé un emprunt national ou
européen pour le fret ferroviaire en
rappelant le caractère d'intérêt général
de son développement j'avais insisté sur
la nécessité de sa maîtrise publique
l'importance du maintien du trafic de
wagon isolé dans la sncf et bien sûr
l'intérêt environnemental
je suis donc attentive à ce plan ferait
dans ce qu'il prévoit le financement des
infrastructures ferroviaires mais je
regrette que les conditions de son
financement et les échéances restent
floues ceci étant l'efficacité de ce
plan qui prévoit la suppression rapide
70% du trafic isolé par l'asm
cf m'interpelle en effet une telle
suppression risque d'enclencher un
cercle vicieux néfaste aux chargeurs aux
activités la sncf au report modal et
traîné face au maillage territorial
aujourd'hui les opérateurs ferroviaires
de proximité sont rares et n'ont pas
prouvé à ce jour leur efficacité par
rapport à la sncf
une disparition brutale du wagon isolé
de la sncf alors qu'on est seulement au
stade de l'émergence de ces opérateurs
se traduirait par un report de 1 à 2
millions de camions supplémentaires par
an sur la route avec le risque avéré et
certains d'un non retour du chargeur sur
le fret ferroviaire
ceci va donc à contre sens de l'objectif
environnemental de report modal de la
route vers le rail
de plus le wagon isolé représente quand
même le tiers du chiffre d'affaires de
fret sncf l'arrêt de cette activité aura
nécessairement des effets sur le
personnel
je crains une privatisation rapide par
la création de filiales de fret
spécialisées avec à la clé la
suppression de près de 4600 emplois
d'autre part si le développement des
autoroutes ferroviaires et bienvenus il
doit être mise en relation avec la
réalité actuelle
13000 poids lourds passent par exemple
quotidiennement sur l'autoroute a1
alors que sur l'autoroute ferroviaire
perpignan bettencourt
seuls 80 remorques sont transportés il y
a donc à revoir les coût réel du
transport routier
et notamment des poids-lourds l'usure de
la chaussée pour un poids lourd
correspond à 600 véhicules de
particuliers
nous sommes donc pour la modulation de
péage mais nous pensons qu'il faut aller
plus loin et ouvrir la voie à
l'internalisation à terme des coûts
externes
c'est le sens de nos amendements aux
mesures relatives aux péages
autoroutiers
à ce propos je m'interroge sur les
conséquences de la mise en place des
télépéages automatiques et l'accès aux
fichiers électroniques des cartes grises
par les sociétés concessionnaires
aire d'autoroute n'est ce pas là une
source de suppression de l'activité
manuelle de la perception des péages le
gouvernement at il prévu des concessions
telles que cela s'est fait dans le cadre
de la privatisation des concessions
d'autoroutes que les entreprises
s'engagent à ce que l'automatisation se
fasse au gré des départs naturels donc
sans mutation ni licenciements
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues sur ce titre
au groupe crc spg nous serons très
soucieux d'une part des garanties
accordées aux salariés dans les domaines
ferroviaire et du télépéage manuel
d'autre part sur la prise en compte du
coût réel du transport routier
sans lequel la révolution verte reste
une illusion d'optique profitable pour
quelques-uns et coûteuse pour la
majorité
notre vote sera donc lié aux garanties
qu'apportera le gouvernement sur ces
questions
je vous remercie merci madame la
sénatrice permettez moi chers collègues
de vous rappeler que les interventions
les prises de parole sur l'article sont
limités à 5 minutes
la parole est à monsieur michel teston
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chères et chers collègues nous
entamons l'examen du titre 2 regroupant
les articles relatifs au transport avant
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet je
souhaite formuler quelques remarques
générales sur la politique des
transports telle qu'elle ressort des
dispositions nous allons débattre
les sénateurs socialistes ont soutenu le
projet de loi du grenelle 1
car il leur est apparu que ces objectifs
étaient parfaitement consensuelle et que
même si le texte n'allait pas toujours
assez loin
il compte tenu des avancées notables en
matière de transport notamment pour ne
citer que deux exemples je ferais
référence aux objectifs de développement
des modes de transports de marchandises
alternatifs à la route et de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
certain nombre de propositions entre en
août étaient prises en compte
le grenat a donc suscité un réel espoir
et notre groupe attendait beaucoup du
second texte portant engagement national
pour l'environnement
qu'en est il s'agissant du volet relatif
au transport
et bien si certaines dispositions du
titre 2 constituent des avancées il n'en
demeure pas moins que le contenu du
texte est assez décevants par rapport
aux attentes suscitées par le grenelle 1
quelles sont les avancées en premier de
notre groupe salue l'inscription dans le
texte de dispositions relatives à
l'autopartage ce mode de déplacement a
toujours été promue par le groupe
socialiste avec en particulier
l'heureuse initiative qu'a constitué la
proposition de loi de relance deuxième
avancée
l'évolution des compétences des
autorités organisatrices de transport
qui devrait améliorer la coordination
des compétences en matière de transport
urbain la troisième avant s'il s'agit
d'un nouvel article et la possibilité
donnée aux autorités organisatrices de
transport d'instituer une taxe
forfaitaire sur le produit de la
valorisation des terrains immeubles
bâtis en vue de la réalisation
d'infrastructures de transports
collectifs en site propre
cela devrait permettre aux collectivités
de trouver d'autres modes de financement
que les 2,5 milliards d'euros promis par
l'état dont seulement 800 millions ont
été programmés je rappelle que les
besoins de financement pour les tcsp
sont estimées à 40 milliards d'euros
dont 26 pour l'île de france à l'horizon
2020 si le texte contient des mesures en
matière de transports urbains
toutes les autres activités du
ferroviaire pourtant un des éléments
phares du grenelle heures sont quasiment
absentes de ce projet de loi
comment ne pas évoquer le plan fret avec
sa réorganisation du transport des
wagons isolés qui n'encourage pas le
report modal bien au contraire
j'y reviendrai à l'article 22 compte
d'une de ces remarques et concerne la
nécessité de développer une politique
des transports plus respectueuse de
l'environnement le groupe socialiste
vous proposera divers amendements de
nature à améliorer le dispositif actuel
il
s'agira principalement de préciser les
activités de transport qui pourront être
prises en charge par les autorités
organisatrices d'apporter des
améliorations dispositif d'autopartage
ou encore de permettre aux collectivités
territoriales financièrement très engagé
d'actionner des leviers financiers
supplémentaires afin de faire face à
leurs charges concernant les péages
notre groupe défendra plusieurs
amendements de nature à améliorer
sensiblement le dispositif actuellement
proposé par le projet de voie nous
proposerons également un dispositif
particulier vise à assujettir les
concessionnaire d'infrastructures
ferroviaires au versement de la tp ou
d'une autre taxe qui lui seraient
substituées à ce stade les sénateurs du
groupe socialiste est rattachée
considère que le texte n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
il manque d'ambition dans son domaine
les transports pourtant très sensible en
matière de protection de l'environnement
nous souhaitons donc améliorer ce texte
tel objet nous amène moi je vois que
monsieur l'ancien premier ministre mme
approuvent
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole est
à monsieur roland ries ce au nom du
groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
m mais chers collègues l'article 16
propose de clarifier les compétences des
collectivités en aménagement et
transport et urbanisme dans un souci
d'amélioration de la planification et la
gestion de tous les modes de transport
il prévoit ainsi d'améliorer la
coordination entre les compétences
transports urbains voirie et
stationnement sur les territoires des
opci dotées de plans de déplacements
urbains
conformément à ce qui avait été
préconisée par le comité opérationnel
sur les transports urbains et
périurbains
si l'article temps un objectif louable
les dispositions proposées sont pourtant
très loin de satisfaire ses ambitions
l'article 16 1 propose de modifier le
code général des collectivités
territoriales dans les intercommunalités
compétente en matière de voirie est
concerné par un
la réglementation du stationnement
serait encadré le maire aurait la
faculté l'interdire de le limiter à
certaines catégories de véhicules ou le
rendre payant et ou limitée dans le
temps
l'objectif ici est je suppose de
faciliter la circulation des véhicules
de transport collectif ou l'accès des
usagers au service cependant disons le
cette disposition ne sent pas réellement
changé l'existant tout d'abord à
l'exception de quelques communautés
urbaines et anciens districts rares sont
les intercommunalités qui dispose de la
compétence voirie en totalité
en outre rien n'impose au maire
d'adopter une réglementation conforme
aux souhaits exprimés par la haute et eu
enfin et c'est probablement le plus
important la question de la gestion du
stationnement ne concerne pas seulement
les abords des lignes supportant la
circulation de véhicules assurant un
service de transport urbain les
objectifs d'une maîtrise intégrée du
stationnement au niveau de
l'agglomération sont de deux ordres
il faut pouvoir gérer les flux lutter
contre les voitures ventouses en
centre-ville et inciter au stationnement
en périphérie grâce à des parkings
relais par exemple et surtout
sanctionner efficacement les
contrevenants nous y reviendrons il ne
peut être réduit à quelques décisions de
police du stationnement sur les grands
axes de circulation
depuis des années les spécialistes
s'accordent sur la nécessité de
décentraliser intégralement le pouvoir
de sanction du stationnement et de
transférer la compétence au niveau
intercommunal de sorte que la personne
publique responsable des déplacements
soient aussi responsables de la
politique du stationnement sur voirie et
en ouvrages c'est le sens de la notion
d'autorité organisatrice des
déplacements ou plus globalement de la
mobilité durable
attardons-nous maintenant mes chers
collègues sur les articles 16 2 et 16 3
qui propose deux mesures touchant les
communautés de communes et les
communautés d'agglomération la première
concerne les voies et trottoirs
supportant la circulation d'un transport
collectif en site propre
elles seront déclarés automatique
d'intérêt communautaire si certaines
intercommunalités au moment de leur
création ont choisi cette règle
déclaration d'intérêt communautaire
automatique des oies de transport ou
encore des voies situées dans les zac
déclarée d'intérêt communautaire il est
important de rappeler que la définition
de l'intérêt communautaire emporte la
définition d'un transfert de charges et
le compensation en échange du transfert
de l'entretien de la voie les équilibres
politiques de nombreuses communautés
pourraient être dérangé par une telle
mesure l'intérêt communautaire était
jusque là une variable d'ajustement
politique librement décidée par les
communes formant l'intercommunalité
définir la majorité qualifiée il
détermine le degré d'intégration du
groupement en conséquence il détermine
aussi le coefficient d'intégration
fiscale qui intervient dans le calcul de
la dgf à plusieurs égards cette mesure
aura des incidences sur les équilibres
financiers les groupements la seconde
mesure vise elle a intégré aux
compétences optionnelles les communautés
de communes et d'agglomération
l'organisation d'un service de mise à
disposition des vélos en libre service
outre le fait que la traduction
législative du concept pose question le
fait d'en faire une compétence
optionnelle sans aucun rapport et la
détention de la compétence transport
déplacements entre en contradiction avec
la notion d'autorité organisatrice des
déplacements pour conforter la logique
d'intégration la compétence transport
déplacements dans les zones urbaines
il est d'ailleurs difficile de ne pas
envisager de modifier la définition du
contenu de la compétence transport
urbain contenus dans la loupe
loties eux mêmes le choix de la création
d'une compétence vélos en libre-service
autopartage stationnement ne peut-elle
se faire sans réflexion sur le niveau
d'exercice la future compétences définir
une compétence est une chose encore
faut-il prévoir à quel niveau cette
compétence sera exercée et c'est le
message que je tenais à exprimer ici
d'emblée je vous remercie mes chers
collègues de votre attention
merci monsieur le sénateur nous abordons
donc les amendement l'amendement
681 présenté par le président à bout
madame la présidente monsieur nuit chers
collègues lorsque la communauté de
communes est compétente en matière de
création ou aménagement et entretien de
voirie communautaire notre amendement
souhaite rappeler qu'il appartient aux
communes membres de déterminer à la
majorité qualifiée l'intérêt
communautaire des voix et de leurs
dépendances
et cette règle bien sûr s'applique
également et à l' inverse en cas de
modification ou de retrait de tout ou
partie de la compétence
tel est le but recherché à vis de la
commissaire à porter à même la
présidente chaque collègue
la commission avait annie un avis
défavorable sur l'amendement initial de
681 rétifié car la notion de portions de
trottoirs adjacents avaient été
supprimés alors qu'elle permet de
répondre au cas par cas aux spécificités
locales
le nouvel amendement dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui rétabli cette notion par
ailleurs la commission n'a pas examiné
ce nouvel amendement mais il me paraît à
titre personnel convenable car il
al'avantage de ne pas créer de nouvelles
règles en matière de déclaration
d'intérêt communautaire en effet je
rappelle que dans les communautés de
communes
contrairement en communauté
d'agglomération et urbaines
cette déclaration est le monopole des
conseils municipaux statuant à la
majorité qualifiée à titre personnel
donc avis favorable à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
sagesse pas de demande de parole je
soumets donc aux voileux 681 rectifié
qu'inquiets ce qui est pour
c'est ce qui est contre il est adopté
nous avons trois amendements en
discussion commune le 346 rectifié bis
c'est monsieur revel qui le présente
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
du transfert de la compétence voirie au
comité à robben sur leur territoire
département nous pouvons supposer que
par une délibération motivée
la réforme territoriale doit d'abord
abordé ce sujet notamment dans le cas de
création d'une métropole et de
l'assouplissement des modalités de
délégations de compétence c'est l'objet
de cet amendement c'est madame cherche
qui présente le 442 qui est identique
oui madame la présidente la commission a
adopté à l'article celle d amendement
qui prévoit le transfert de la gestion
des voiries départementales aux
communautés urbaines ou d'agglomération
d'aucuns diront qu'il s'agit d'une
invitation a signé des conventions
mais le refus pour le département de
délégué sa compétence en matière de
voirie nécessite tout de même une
délibération motivée
ce transfert implique aussi la mise à
disposition des services départementaux
en charge de la voirie par voie de
conséquence un dessaisissement du
département les amendements du
rapporteur tend alors à redéfinir les
compétences entre les communautés
d'agglomération ou urbaines et le
département
bien sûr nous ne supportons pas
d'arrière pensée particulière dans la
rédaction de cet article 16 et ne
contestons pas qu'il soit important
d'assurer une gestion intégrée des
transports en commun en site propre
il nous semble prématuré de redéfinir
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi les
compétences des collectivités
territoriales sans avoir eu
préalablement le débat sur la réforme
des collectivités territoriales c'est
anticiper les débats parlementaires sur
cette question c'est pourquoi je demande
la suppression du deuxième terre nouveau
et du 3e c de l'article 16 qui conduit
sa transférée à la communauté urbaine où
la communauté d'agglomération l'exercice
de compétence du département en matière
de voirie placement des classements plan
d'alignement coordination des travaux
affectant le sol le sous-sol en dehors
des agglomérations
bien le 455 rectifié tombe
je demande donc à la commission son avis
sur les deux amendements qui viennent
d'être présentés monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente chocolate
il est tout à fait possible
qu'effectivement nous rentrions dans le
vif du sujet sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales
prochainement pour autant comme je l' ai
déjà dit mme eyoum pas peur il s'agit de
transport collectif il s'agit de
transport en commun dans lequel il
s'agit de conventions que nous passons
volontairement entre les départements et
une communauté urbaine par exemple pour
améliorer les transports collectifs
si d'aventuré demain matin le rapport du
gouvernement le projet de loi de
modification de réforme territoriale
modifie les choses très bien
eh bien on modifiera mais au moins de
grâce faisons en sorte que ces
transports en commun fonctionnent et
donnons-nous les moyens de notre
politique à vis du gouvernement la
commission donné un avis favorable
également pas de demande de parole je
mets aux voies d'abord oui alors nous
avons une demande de scrutin public de
la commission donc non il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront aux secrétaires un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettront un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un
bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
ty clos j'invite mesdames et messieurs
les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
on a
alors résultats du scrutin numéro 217
sur les amendements 346 rectifié bis et
442 nombre de votants 323 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
323 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 162 pour l'adoption 137 contre
le sénat n'a pas adopté trois
amendements en discussion commune le 347
rectifié bis tombe
ah non pardon monsieur reuver pardonnez
moi vous avez la parole
merci mr la présidente
ce ministre et chaque collègue c'est la
même motivation que le mandement
précédent à savoir que dès lors qu'il va
y avoir bientôt une réforme territoriale
et une redéfinition des compétences
il paraîtrait assez légitime que
l'ensemble des nouvelles dispositions
puissent est examinée à cette occasion
c'est l'objet de cet amendement que je
présente au nom de monsieur du luart
comme le précédent et de monsieur leroy
le 443-1 présenté par madame ch
écoutez c'est le même pratiquement que
le précédent donc c'est dans la même
logique en attendant la réforme nous
aurions souhaité supprimer le petit cdu
troisièmement pour ne pas anticiper sur
justement cette fameuse réforme des
collectivités territoriales et sa voix
qui organisera réellement les transports
bien à vis de la commission relève le
président chers collègues
les mêmes causes produisent les mêmes
effets c'est ce que notre honorable
collègues reuver avait constaté
effectivement je crois que il faut aller
de l'avant dans un domaine où l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens attendent qu'on
prenne des positions claires et qu'on
n'attende pas de recul et de retarder
je pense donc qu'il faut d'avis
défavorables même avis monsieur le
ministre je suppose
est ce que je peux vous le maintenez il
est retiré la retirer maintenu sur le
443 est-ce que je peux déduire du vote
précédent qu'il est le même
je pense même vote donc il n'est pas
adoptée le 4 156 est tombé après
l'article 16 amendements numéro 4 174
monsieur roland rice
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues 1 si j'ai
décidé de présenter de défendre cet
amendement c'est parce que la situation
actuelle du stationnement payant en
milieu urbain notamment n'est
satisfaisante pour personne
le rapport de synthèse publiée en 2005
établi par l'inspection générale des
finances des services judiciaires de
l'administration et du conseil général
des ponts et chaussées et sur ce point
sans appel il est dit dans ce rapport
que la verbalisation du stationnement
payant et je suit inefficace obsolète
peu transparents et la chaîne de
traitement des amendes reflète l'absence
de politique de stationnement payant fin
de citation
on peut y lire plus loin que plusieurs
raisons pourrait conduire l'état à se
désengager de ce dossier incapacité
jusqu'à ce jour à construire une
véritable politique et à coordonner les
acteurs incapacité et complexité du
système équilibre financier incertain je
cite toujours le rapport il est vrai
qu'en la matière et pour reprendre une
fois de plus les conclusions de ce
rapport
je cite encore l'insertion du
stationnement payant dans une politique
publique de déplacement urbain est un
objectif prioritaire
elle conditionne la maîtrise et le
partage de la voirie et constitue un
levier essentiel de l'aménagement urbain
il ya d'ailleurs à ce sujet un rapport
qui a été fait il ya une dizaine
d'années par deux chercheurs l'un
français jean marie gleize et l'autre
suisse vincent kaufmann qui démontre le
caractère stratégique de l'offre de
stationnement pour le choix modal selon
qu'on a de l'offre de stationnement en
nombre suffisant et pas trop cher on
incite les gens à prendre ou à ne pas
prendre la voiture c'est est démontré
très clairement dans non ce rappel dans
ce rapport auquel je vous renvoie ce
rapport je reviens ici à celui dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
estime que le contenu de l'inscription
du stationnement payant dans les
politiques de déplacement et maîtrise à
warri
les collectivités territoriales sont
mieux placés que l'état pour conduire
dans un cadre territorialisée les
évolutions nécessaires
le recentrage de l'état sur ses
fonctions essentiellement devant le
conduire à abandonner la compétence de
stationnement payant tel est le sens mes
chers collègues de l'amendement que je
soumets à l'appréciation notre assemblée
aujourd'hui cet amendement reprend
presque à l'identique celui qu'avait
proposé christian philip
à l'assemblée nationale en 2005 des
années passent mais les problèmes
restent
il a pour objectif d'améliorer le
traitement des infractions mis en oeuvre
en cas de manquement par les
automobilistes aux obligations liées au
stationnement payant sur voirie et de
renforcer la maîtrise des collectivités
locales sur les dix poti dispositif
général du stationnement payant pour en
faire un instrument au service de la
politique de déplacement
le projet d'amendement présenté vise à
étendre au stationnement payant sur
voirie qui relève aujourd'hui du régime
des contraventions pénal de la première
classe un mécanisme de transactions
comparables à celui qui existe pour les
infractions commises en matière de
transports publics à la sncf à la ratp
ou dans les transports urbains
le dispositif proposé offrira aux
contrevenants à l'obligation d'acquitter
la redevance de ces schémas la
possibilité de régler par la voie d'une
transaction une redevance forfaitaire
auprès de l'autorité compétente
en pratique les dispositions prévues par
l'amendement remplaceront la menthe
forfaitaire actuel de 11 euros
de nature pénale par une redevance
forfaitaire fixée par les autorités
organisatrices locale le payement de la
redevance forfaitaire ainsi que son
tarif seront donc établi pour les
emplacements de stationnement payant par
le maire le conseil municipal où
l'organe délibérant de l'établissement
public de coopération intercommunale ou
du syndicat mixte compétent pour
l'organisation des transports urbains
le dispositif a en effet vocation à
s'appliquer quelle que soit le fondement
juridique qui a présidé à l'instauration
du stationnement payant
qu'ils soient issus du pouvoir de police
du maire
ou d'une compétence de gestion domaniale
cet amendement vous l'aurez donc compris
temps à vouloir corriger les
dysfonctionnements constatés en matière
de stationnement payant et permettre
ainsi de donner aux collectivités
territoriales les moyens de mettre en
oeuvre une politique de déplacements
urbains et de maîtrise de la voirie ce
faisant et pour conclure mes chers
collègues l'amendement que je défends
est conforme aux engagements cas des
prix nicolas sarkozy dans un courrier
qu'il avait adressée à mon prédécesseur
du gart michel destot nicolas sarkozy
avait en effet écrit je cite vouloir
donner au maire ou aux présidents
d'agglomération qui le demandent
l'instrument d'une politique
volontariste des déplacements urbains
les pleines compétences sur le
stationnement
ce qui suppose de dépénaliser les
infractions de stationnement sur voirie
je souhaite que cette c'est monsieur le
président la république s'exprime que
cette décentralisation se fasse à la
carte pour que chaque collectivité soit
libre de choisir soit une nouvelle
procédure décentralisée soit la
procédure administré par l'état laisse
les choses ouverte dans la procédure
décentralisée la collectivité sera libre
de moduler tous les tarifs
elle sera responsable du contrôle et du
recouvrement et bien entendu recevra le
produit des redevances et amant je serai
donc surpris mes chers collègues que
vous ne nous rejoigne et pas sur cette
voie dans la mesure où cet amendement
reprend l'essentiel des engagements que
le président de la république avait fait
à l'occasion de sa campagne électorale
merci de respecter cet engagement à vis
de la commission
notre collègue roland ries sa
d'excellentes références président de la
république c'est certain et donc est
donc votre commission il s'agit d'un
amendement très intéressant qui aborde
le ministre confiant qu'ils confient
qu'ils abordent la question de la
réforme du stationnement payant non par
la voie de la dépénalisation mais par la
voie de la transaction étape
intermédiaire entre le paiement à
l'horodateur et l'amande
à titre personnel je pense que cet
amendement ne va pas assez loin car il
court car il conserve le caractère pénal
en cas d'infraction mais la rédaction
propose est intéressante et pourra
utilement alimenter la réflexion du
groupe de travail commun en commission
de l'économie des finances et des lois
sur la réforme de la politique du
stationnement
donc je veux demander soit le retrait
soit je mettrais un avis défavorable
pour autant pour autant pour autant
chers collègues pour autant chers
collègues quand on lit effectivement ce
rapport de l'inspection générale des
finances des services judiciaires de
l'administration et du conseil général
des ponts et chaussées eh bien il ya de
quoi effectivement se dire qu'il est
temps de travailler sur ce dossier
que dit ce rapport de 2005 il dit le
taux de paiement spontanée est de
l'ordre de 35% en moyenne en france est
beaucoup plus faible à paris où ils
atteindraient simplement le taux de 10%
de paiement spontanée ce rapport dit le
produit global des redevances de
stationnement n'est pas connu aucune
centralisation des fêtes
ce rapport dit le montant global
recouvre et au titre des amendes n'est
pas connu car il ne fait pas l'objet
d'un suivi spécifique et il termine par
une conclusion une évolution profonde et
globale du système est donc
indispensable
c'est pourquoi je souhaite monsieur le
ministre en notre présence vous demander
d'examiner avec attention
je dirai ce dossier merci ne cédera
porter à vis du gouvernement
merci madame la présidente président
monsieur rapporte holmes et messieurs
les sénateurs
l'amendement déposé par roland ries
c'est un amendement que nous comprenons
parfaitement
il a été il est le président du gart
rapporterait moi-même en avons été
vice-président donc nous connaissons
bien cette demande des collectivités et
j'avais moi-même en d'autres temps
confié à christian philip alors député
du rhône un rapport dont c'était roland
ries s'en souvient et louis nerfs
également une des conclusions ce que je
crois c'est que il est encore un peu tôt
pour voter ça pour deux raisons 1
parce que on n'a pas réglé tout le
problème de la pénalisation et nous
avons actuellement un travail qui est
engagée avec le ministère de l'intérieur
et demie stade la justice pour régler ce
point 2 je le vois en tant que président
d'un département
c'est une ressource par la péréquation
non négligeable pour nos petites
collectivités donc il faut qu'on règle
ce problème de ressources et de
péréquation pour l'été une collectivité
je pense que leur apporterait est tout à
fait décidé à s'engager sur ce sujet le
gouvernement est prêt à travailler avec
lui on n'en est pas loin
mais monsieur risque pas aujourd'hui
nous sommes pas encore prêts
techniquement c'est une réforme que j'ai
reçu certaines se fera parce qu'elle est
d'ailleurs très consensuel dans notre
pays donc pour les mêmes raisons que le
rapporteur sans émettre de jugements
négatifs sur le fond mais en opportunité
j'émets un avis défavorable et je serais
heureux vous puissiez éventuellement
retirer cet amendement mais qu'en tant
que président du gart
nous continuons du travail ensemble je
pense que nous sommes pas loin de
trouver une solution intelligente
monsieur risque quel est votre décision
présidente le ministre
vous êtes peut-être pas prêt c'est
peut-être pas le moment mais ça fait dix
ans que ça dure ça fait dix ans que ça
dure et et les gouvernements successifs
ont opposé des commissions d des
réflexions complémentaires c'est pas le
moment
c'est pourtant quelque chose de simple
le système ne fonctionne pas aujourd'hui
louis le rapporteur le rappelait
tout à l'heure 10% des du produit des
amendes est effectivement perçu 10 % et
encore des amendes à 11 euros qu'ils
soient absolument pas d'issue est donc
moi je pense que je m'exprime en mon nom
personnel mais c'est vrai que l'ensemble
des autorités organisatrices le droite
et de gauche
je le dois dire ici sont unanimes
là-dessus il faut vraiment qu'on avance
là-dessus donc je maintiens 7
cet amendement parce que il me paraît
paraît nécessaire de le maintenir et que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités
monsieur ninis fourcade
merci madame la présidence moi je
comprends monsieur ris je comprends sur
l'amendement puisque au comité des
finances locales ont évoqué ce problème
m emprise ceci dit il ya deux
difficultés
la première c'est que personne ne sait
exactement s'il ya un écart entre les
sommes effectivement collecté par l'état
au titre des amendes et les sommes
reversées aux collectivités locales
on calcule chaque année une valeur de
poing et personne n'a encore vérifié la
mission d'inspection dans la pas fait
s'il y'avait adéquation entre les deux
s'il n'ya pas adéquation il est clair
que l'article 40 est applicable puisque
ça privent l'êta d'un certain nombre de
recettes
deuxièmement il est évident que dans ce
système là alors qu'aujourd'hui les
amendes seront couvrait par le service
public des comptables publics dans le
système que vous proposez les amendes
seront recouvrait par chaque
collectivité et il fallait il faudra
donc créer à l'intérieur des communautés
urbaines des communautés d'agglomération
ou des coûts des communautés ou de
commune ou des communes un service de
recouvrement avec tous les problèmes et
ce qui gêne dans cette affaire c'est le
maintien de la dualité entre le
recouvrement par la collectivité
territoriale et le caractère pénal de
celui qui ne veut pas la pénalité
applicable à celui qui ne veut pas payer
c'est pourquoi j'ai entendu avec
beaucoup d'intérêt la la position car
nous a présenté
monsieur le ministre bussereau je
voudrais avec monsieur reste dire qu'il
faut maintenant se dépêcher je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse voter aujourd'hui ce
texte et par conséquent le groupe ump ne
le votera pas mais monsieur le ministre
je crois qu'on ne peut pas laisser ouf
r ce chantier il faut régler le problème
de l'adéquation entre le recouvrement et
la distribution
il faut régler le problème de la
pénalité qui peut subsister et je crois
que le gouvernement serait bien venu de
nous faire une proposition assez
rapidement mais dans l'hypothèse
actuelle nous suivrons le gouvernement
ne voudront pas cet amendement pas
d'autres demandes d'explication je mets
aux voix le 474 qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adoptée après
l'article 16
le 683 c'est monsieur lise qui le
présente
si madame la présidente monsieur
ministère collègues à la martinique la
situation du transport interurbain de
personnes demeurent particulièrement
préoccupante en dépit il faut le dire
des efforts considérables réalisés par
le département et la région dans ce
domaine notamment en matière
d'infrastructures haut se heurte en
effet à une difficulté majeure pour
organiser un service répondant aux
attentes des usagers et aux impératifs
d'un développement durable et solidaire
l'existence sur un territoire de 1100
kilomètres carrés de 16 autorités
organisatrices la région le département
deux communautés d'agglomération
regroupant 24 communes sur 34
un syndicat mixte en charge d'un tcsp et
onze communes et en créer 1 pt il en
résulte un conflit de compétence et un
manque de cohérence dans les politiques
menées source de difficultés
d'inefficacité d'inégalité en termes
d'aménagement du territoire et
répartition des ressources mais aussi de
nuisances environnementales le
territoire de la martinique est en fait
à l'échelle d'une grande agglomération
de l'hexagone comme celle de
saint-etienne par exemple ou d'une
communauté aubaine comme celle de lyon 2
toulouse et devrait de reconstituer un
périmètre unique de transport
il s'agit donc par cet amendement et sur
la base des dispositions de l'article 73
alinéa 3 de la constitution
habilité le conseil général de la
martinique à instaurer un tel périmètre
unique de transport
celui ci sera géré par une autorité
unique établi dans le cadre d'une
concertation locale associant toutes les
collectivités actuellement une
compétence en ce domaine ainsi que les
représentants des transporteurs et des
usagers une telle demande d'habilitation
a déjà fait l'objet de deux
délibérations adoptées à l'unanimité par
les conseillers généraux réunis en
assemblée plénière en novembre 2007 et
en juin 2008 le conseil général a suivi
strictement la procédure prévue par la
loi organique du 20 21 février 2007 il a
sollicité l'avis des conseils
consultatifs avant transmission au
premier ministre et au représentant de
l'état lequel il faut le souligner n'a
pas déferré la délibération devant le
conseil d'état
la demande n'a cependant jusqu'ici pas
abouti pour souligner l'importance de
l'enjeu pour la martinique est en accord
avec le conseil général le conseil
régional entrepris une demande
d'habilitation similaire également
restée lettre morte à différentes
reprises les deux exécutifs ont attiré
l'attention du gouvernement sur cette
situation mais n'ont jamais pu obtenir
d'explications claires et précises
l'ancien secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer
yves jégo s'est contenté de lancer au
cours d'une audition sénatoriales public
les demandes ne sont pas légales quant à
vous monsieur le secrétaire d'état vous
avez exprimé sur le sujet une position
que j'ai trouvé assez déconcertante
dans un courrier du 23 janvier de cette
année vous m'indiquer en effet que grâce
à un amendement voté dans le cadre du
grenelle 1
l'étape désormais le terme le terme
désormais a toute son importance
l'étape désormais prendre des
dispositions spécifiques en faveur des
transports collectifs d'outre-mer comme
si vous vouliez ignorer l'existence de
l'article 73 de la constitution article
sur lequel se fonde pourtant
l'amendement cités sont d'ailleurs que
celui ci apporte quoi que ce soit de
plus que ce qui est prévu par la
constitution
c'est un amour bonne complaisance en
réalité l'article 73 de la constitution
faut-il le rappeler aux touristes des
adaptations aux situations particulières
des dom et depuis la réforme de 2003
permet aux départements et régions
d'outre-mer d'obtenir du parlement des
habilitations à procéder à de telles
adaptations
l'occasion nous est donc donné
aujourd'hui sur un sujet important et
sur lequel les élus martiniquais sont
unanimes je le précise de mesurer
l'intérêt réel des dispositions figurent
en troisième alinéa de l'article 73 de
la constitution
ensuite je demande d'abord l'avis de la
commission vous aurez la parole tout à
l'heure mon cher collègue madame la
présidente sue ministre collègues
cet amendement monsieur lise ne va pas
laisser indifférent avant de s'attarder
sur le fond de l'amendement un point de
droit constitutionnel
si je comprends bien le secrétariat
d'état à exercer pour ainsi dire son
droit de veto en refusant de faire
paraître au journal officiel la
délibération du conseil général de
martinique de 2007
à cette occasion je ne peut que citer le
rapport de la mission commune
d'information du sénat sur la situation
des départements d'outre-mer présidée
par notre collègue monsieur eric doligé
la mission la mission tient bien la
mission tient rappelé avec force et vous
serez d'accord avec ça que la loi
organique du 21 février 2007 ne prévoit
que l'exercice d'un contrôle de légalité
des délibérations prises par les
conseils généraux et régionaux
d'outre-mer en application de l'article
73 de la constitution
elle n'autorise aucunement le
gouvernement exerce un contrôle
d'opportunité sur ses délibérations
voilà ce que disait la mission sur le
fond on ne peut qu'être favorable sur le
principe de créer un périmètre unique de
transport et une autorité organisatrice
de transport unique car il n'est pas
acceptable
en effet de conserver 16 à ôter sur un
territoire grand comme un cinquième d'un
département métropolitain
toutefois toutefois toutefois
l'amendement de détermine partie de la
région ou du département sera la haute
et alors que la procédure
d'expérimentation prévu expressément par
l'article 73 de la constitution
nécessite cette précision
par conséquent par conséquent j'ai mis
la vie fade défavorable tout un stéphane
wable tout en souhaitant que l'on trouve
rapidement une solution à cette
situation peu satisfaisante et je me
retourne
monsieur lise peut-être vers monsieur le
ministre
avis défavorable à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre la présidente le
gouvernement et met le même avis à
partir du moment où l'ensemble des
collectivités concernant martinique nous
ont pas donné le même sentiment sur
cette affaire et en particulier pas
l'agglomération de fort de france et on
peut pas dans un département faire
quelque chose en jouant le conseil
général contre d'agglomération les uns
les autres d'ailleurs n'étonne pas dans
la majorité présidentielle
vous savez encore plus à l'aise pour
dire que le gouvernement suit le
rapporteur ou s'en remet à la sagesse de
la haute assemblée alors monsieur
larcher vous aviez demandé la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
secrétaire d'état mes chers collègues je
voulais tout de suite fait rappeler à
monsieur le rapporteur que c est bien
sert larcher qui préside la mission
commune d'information sur les
départements d'outre-mer et je les vis
tout de suite allé le rapport pas
seulement la partie concernant le
transport mais tout l'ensemble du
rapport
il souhaite ici soutenir l'amendement
déposé par mon collègue claude lise
l'organisme transports collectifs
urbains et interurbains constitue un
véritable enjeu de développement durable
pour la martinique compte tenu de
l'exiguïté du territoire et de la
croissance de son parc automobile
le réseau routier est aujourd'hui saturé
les initiatives des collectivités
locales en matière de transports
collectifs ont conduit à des
améliorations notables mais il est
certain que
chevènement de compétences entre les
différentes autorités organisatrices de
transport nuit à l'efficacité de
l'action publique dans les départements
d'outre-mer les compétences en matière
de transport sont en effet répartis
entre les conseils généraux les conseils
régionaux les communes enfin et les
goûts et le groupement afin de
rationaliser la répartition des
compétences et d'optimiser l'action
publique
il paraît donc utile qu'une autorité
unique soient mises en place sur un
périmètre unique de transport
c'est une des évidences qui ressort des
analyses de la mission d'information que
j'ai moi même des idées sur la situation
des départements d'outre-mer
c'est même une des propositions de cette
mission dont la conclusion est adoptée
de manière très consensuelle de plus
l'amendement présenté par mon collègue
ne fait que reprendre les demandes de
conseil général transmet par deux fois
au gouvernement
mais malgré certaines promesses ou quand
suite n'a été donnée à sa demande
cette faculté est clamé par les cultes
par les collectivités de la martinique
de pouvoir adapter le doit à leur
situation spécifique comme le permet la
constitution dans son article 73 vient
de vient de s'accorder au département de
la guyane de 4 da dans la loi du 27 mai
2009 plein développement économique des
outre-mer
il est donc difficile de comprendre
aujourd'hui qu'il existe un tel blocage
sur cette question des transports
d'autant que la solution proposée
aujourd'hui fait l'objet d'un très large
consensus
je veux bien qu'on me pose la non
réponse de la dollar d'admiration devant
le france mais ici il y a une volonté
qui est pas varela par l'ensemble de la
population arctique est d'arriver à ce
transport unique cette autorité unique
se périment est unique nous sommes
bloqués il s'agit dit
dit il et c'est une mesure de sauvegarde
de l'intérêt des martiniquais sinon mes
chaises a fait c'est ici que ne t'ont
pas entendu qu'on arrive à des
extrémités comme qu'on a connus au début
de l'année
je demande à monsieur secrétaire d'état
de reprendre sa propose de cette
proposition enfin de la faire aboutir au
plus vite parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui asphyxiée à la martinique
mais ses ministres même la présidente
vous connaissez bien
l'outre-mer vous avez été plaisant des
commissions des lois de l'assemblée
nationale nous y sommes rendus à
plusieurs reprises ensemble sommes tous
favorables et des l'outre-mer à son
développement et nous sommes très
favorables à ce qu'il y ait une
véritable politique des transports
outre-mer avec des moyens d'aider
transport collectif digne de ce nom
je vais la semaine prochaine à la
réunion où il ya un projet de tram-train
qui est porté par l'ensemble des
collectivités de manière unanime
comprendrait quand même si messieurs les
sénateurs que dans un département où il
n'y a pas accord sur ce sujet entre
l'agglomération de fort de france et le
département
ce n'est pas au gouvernement de trancher
ce n'est pas dans l'esprit de l'article
73 donc débrouillez vous et après on
fera ce que vous souhaitez
collectivement monsieur larcher vous
avez demandé la parole je vous la donne
au fus explicite qui a été formulée par
écrit par la ville de fort de france
non non mais bien parce qu'on ne sait
pas mais je le dis monsieur guillaume a
demandé la parole comme la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le ministre d'état lors de la discussion
générale d'ouverture avait indiqué que
l'enjeu du grenelle de l'environnement
numéro deux était de l'enjeu planétaire
et qu'il fallait non seulement qu'il y
ait des intentions mais qu'il y ait des
actes et c'est l'objet de ce grenelle ii
ici même
c'est que nous indiquions nous des actes
nouveau dans le cadre de ce texte de loi
afin de montrer à nos concitoyens de
montrer aux associations de montrer à
tous ceux qui s'intéressent de près que
le sénat aujourd'hui en débat à
la volonté d'aller plus loin à plusieurs
reprises on nous dit mais c'est une
bonne idée mais demain après nous nous
sommes nous ne sommes pas prêts je pense
que deuxième point de mon intervention
là encore ce n'est pas après mais c'est
maintenant qu'il faut des actes je vous
rappellerai pas les fameux intervention
de clemenceau quand on veut noyer le
poisson qu'on veut tuer un sujet en
créer une commission
enfin si vous me le permettez il y a
dans cet hémicycle trois représentants
de l'outre-mer deux se sont exprimés en
leur qualité et fonctions leur
responsabilité et je pense qu'il est de
notre devoir à nous sénateurs de france
au même titre que nos collègues de
martinique de suivre l'avis éclairé de
deux de nos collègues qui ont une
responsable des responsabilités
éminentes l'un au niveau territorial
l'autre comme président de la commission
de l'inscrire le grenat et nous verrons
bien comment les choses avancent tout à
l'heure l'intervention de nos collègues
lisez et l'arche été très clair il s'est
quand même passé des choses en outre-mer
et dans leur département et dans leur
région il ya quelques mois et les fameux
états généraux quand nous condamnons il
faut bien qu'il débouche sur quelque
chose alors là lorsque les élus du
territoire les élus de ce département
ont une idée globale commune mais ont
donné on ne demande jamais un référendum
on ne demande jamais lorsqu'un sujet se
passe dans un département métropolitain
si toutes les communes tous les villages
tous les hameaux toutes les cuves des
deux communes la bio sont d'accord là il
ya une volonté unanime d'aller de
l'avant
moi je demande vraiment à nos collègues
de la de la haute assemblée de suivre
nos collègues sénateurs d'outre-mer et
d'afficher clairement la volonté qu'il y
a ce serait un acte fort en direction de
l'outre-mer ça serait un acte fort dans
le cadre de ce titre parce que nous
voulons faire en sorte que la
circulation se passe le mieux possible
je crois vraiment que dans le cadre de
l'actualité et de ce qui s'est passé
la sagesse de cette assemblée serait de
suivre nos collègues merci monsieur le
ministre
la présidente veut pas regarder le débat
je rappelle que la position du
gouvernement est la sagesse et que
j'observais avec beaucoup d'attention le
vote du groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
qui suivra le vote de monsieur letchimy
mais ce sera dans un autre moment
monsieur lise et puis nous passons vote
la présidente président je crois que le
problème est là le maire de fort de
france était précédemment président de
la communauté d'agglo je suis assez
étonné de voir le gouvernement essayer
d'arbitrer des conflits locaux entre
entre un an trois élus de gauche mais je
veux vous signalez monsieur le ministre
que depuis mars 2008 la la présidence de
la communauté d'agglo a changé
premièrement donc il s'agit de l'ami
politique très proche de ma formation
politique qui à l'heure actuelle at de
la blue premièrement deuxièmement sur un
point simplement de doigts la loi
organique du 21 février 2007 ne prévoit
absolument pas la consultation des
communautés d'agglo nous avons suivi une
procédure qui est prévu dans une loi
organique
on l'a suivi street de manière stricte
et nous avons envoyé des délibérations
et nous prouvions d'ailleurs attaqué le
fait que délibérément le gouvernement
n'a pas publié au journal officiel
une délibération il n'avait pas le droit
de ne pas de ne pas publier au journal
officiel
par conséquent on se rend bien compte
que dans cette affaire il y a
il vit à réellement d'un point de vue
très politicien que je suis obligé de
dénoncer on essaie d'arbitrer entre deux
composantes qui malheureusement
actuellement ont quelques problèmes au
pays
mais je veux d'ailleurs pour terminer
vous dire également que les élus proches
de monsieur letchimy ont voté au conseil
général
par deux fois puisque nous avons eu
l'unanimité sur la question qui est
soulevée aujourd'hui oui monsieur le
président madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues ce
qu'elle s'était rappelée par notre
collègue guillaume ou le ministre d'état
bien sûr ego de soutien sur le
secrétaire d'état qui avait une prise en
compte de l'environnement sur l'ensemble
de notre planète et j'ai bien entendu
les arguments notre rapporteur qui
révélait un problème local
autrement je crois que nous n'avons pas
nous opposer à cette proposition et
monsieur le ministre a invité notre
assemblée est la sagesse pour
l'expérience que j'ai sur le ministre la
sagesse va plutôt vers une tendance
favorable à l'amendement mais shaun
ellis vous vouliez ajouté non très bien
donc je mets je mets aux voix
l'amendement 683 pied pour
16 17 18 19 20 à ses formidables qui est
contre pas d'abstention il est adopté
l'appel à la solidarité a marché le 684
présentée par monsieur lisent les madame
la présidente puisque c'était une autre
procédure que nous utilisions ou le même
objet retirer retirer le 686 c'est
monsieur rice ou monsieur testons
monsieur rice oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
il s'agit effectivement d'un amendement
qui vise à intégrer le covoiturage
l'autopartage et les systèmes de mise à
disposition de bicyclettes en libre
service dans les compétences des
autorités organisatrices donc d'élargir
au fond la compétence telle qu'elle est
définie dans la loti à ces sept
nouvelles
ces nouvelles offres de déplacements qui
sont apparus notamment pour ce qui
concerne le vélo en libre service
récemment fait une position qui me
paraît une bonne position de bon sens
qui devrait permettre notamment de je
dirais armes et les autorités
organisatrices contre les recours en
abus de pouvoir qui pourraient venir de
particuliers ou d'associations qui ne
seraient pas d'accord avec la mise en
place de ces dispositifs
on sait bien aujourd'hui que les
autorités organisatrices
à partir du moment où elles ont la
responsabilité du service public de
transport dans sa diversité doivent
pouvoir avoir l'ensemble de la boîte à
outils dans laquelle elle puiseront pour
je dirais privilégié tellement doute l
autre en fonction des zones de
pertinence des différents modes le vélo
à sa zone de pertinence qui n'est pas la
zone de pertinence de la voiture
privatives qui n'est pas la zone de
pertinence de l'autopartage
qui n'est pas la zone de pertinence et
le moment de pertinence du covoiturage
bref ces données aux autorités
organisatrices la pleine maîtrise de
l'offre de déplacement sur leur
territoire c'est le sens de cet
amendement qui me paraît être un
amendement de bon sens très bien à vis
de la commission mais sur le rapporteur
1 la présidente monsieur ministre chers
collègues ont soit l'intention des
auteurs de l'amendement est tout à fait
louable
le problème est que l'article de
rattachement
l'article 7 de la loti n'est pas adapté
car il vise cet article 7 les transports
réguliers de personnes d'une part et les
services de transport à la demande
d'autre part or le covoiturage
n'appartient pas à proprement parler à
l'une de ces deux catégories
car il s'agit d'une initiative privée
organisée par les particuliers quant à
l'autopartage l'article 19 du projet de
loi l'inscrit déjà dans la loppsi
j'ajouterai enfin que ces préoccupations
ont été entendus lors de l'examen de
l'article 12 du grenelle 1
en conséquence pour la commission avis
défavorable à vis du gouvernement sur le
686 la présidente je voudrais demander à
roland ries de retirer parce que je
crois qu'avec cet amendement on se tire
une balle dans le pied et qu on
complique les politiques qu'il souhaite
mener que nous que je pense sur tous les
bancs de l'assemblée le souhaitons mener
aux sommes tous favorables au
covoiturage et l'autopartage toutes nos
collectivités prennent des initiatives
la bicyclette bien sûr mais à partir du
moment où monsieur le sénateur hills où
vous relier cela à l'article 7 de la
loti combien l'indiqué le rapporteur
vous obliger à des inscriptions régis de
transporter phase obligeait toute une
série de mesures de démarches
réglementaires qui peuvent compliquer y
compris la mise en oeuvre par une
communauté d'agglomération une
communauté urbaine de ces politiques
donc je comprends tout à fait votre
attention je la partage nous la
partageons tous
mais le rattachement vous faites à
l'article 7 ennuyé beaucoup de
collectivités pour mettre en oeuvre ses
politiques
donc je pense qu'il faut mieux leur
t-rex et que nous regardions avec vous
d'ici là lecture une autre lecture et
que à l'assemblée comment nous pourrions
bien relier votre demande
là je pense que vous allez créer des
complications pour le faire ces raisons
que je vous demande le retrait
partageant votre objectif naturellement
monsieur rice ce ministre chaque
collègue s'il s'agit d'une difficulté je
dirais juridique je suis prêt à retirer
cet amendement
mais j'insiste sur le fait qu' il me
paraît souhaitable que les autorités
organisatrices locales et la maîtrise de
l'ensemble de l'offre de déplacement et
qu' elle puisse privilégier telle offre
ou tel autre offre en fonction des
situations locales et en fonction de ce
que j'appelais tout à l'heure les autres
de pertinence alors je veux bien qu'il
puisse y avoir peut-être une difficulté
mais je souhaiterais ministre que très
clairement on aille dans le sens de ce
que nous appelons hogarth la création de
deux dindes à champ plus large de
compétences pour les autorités
organisatrices les autorités
organisatrices de développement durable
c'est ce que nous c'est la formule que
nous utilisons
alors si vous prenez un engagement je
retire c'est un moment l'amendement 686
est retiré nous abordons l'article 17
avec une demande de parole de monsieur
roland ries ce vous avez la parole
monsieur le sénateur merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues l'article 17 prévoit
donc d'étendre la possibilité d'avoir
recours à la procédure d'extrême urgence
du code de l'expropriation pour les
projets de tramway ou de transport en
commun en site propre
la décision serait prise par un arrêté
préfectoral
il s'agit donc de permettre la prise de
possession rapide des terrains non bâtis
situés sur les emprises des ouvrages
moyennant le paiement d'une indemnité
provisionnelle au moins égal au prix
déterminé par les domaines
ces dispositions visent à réduire les
délais de procédures et améliorer la
maîtrise foncier pour les opérations
elle permet ainsi de satisfaire certains
besoins urgents pour le désenclavement
des quartiers prioritaires tous ceux qui
ont eu en charge des projets de
transport en commun en site propre
savent combien c'est procédure retardent
la réalisation de ces projets et je dois
dire que en tant que président du gart
et maire de la ville de strasbourg
je voudrais souligner l'intérêt
qu'auront les collectivités à la mise en
place de ce dispositif qui devrait
faciliter accéléré je dirais la mise en
oeuvre de leurs projets a strasbourg par
exemple certaines extensions du réseau
de tramway est prévue à notre scot
on appelle ça le scoters chez nous
nécessite l'activation de procédure en
particulier prolongement d'un certain
nombre de lignes mais aussi de ligne
bhns bus à haut niveau de service mais
je pourrais citer d'autres exemples cher
à notre rapporteur par exemple la ligne
numéro un du syndicat intercommunal des
transports publics de cannes a besoin
elle aussi du dispositif sur certains
segments du tracé à l'ouest du périmètre
des transports urbains anime plusieurs
expropriations sont envisagées dans le
cadre du projet de la ligne
deux transports collectifs en site
propre qui doit être mis en service fin
2013 si on n'y prête pas attention ce ne
sera pas possible à nice côte d'azur
cette procédure pourrait concerner
l'extension de la ligne t1 du tramway et
de pont michel à la trinité sur la
branche rive droite du tramway t2 b sur
saint laurent du var et cagnes sur mer
se rapporte à cagnes sur mer et sur la
branche du tramway remontant dans la
plaine du var t3 de saint-augustin à
laon ghost hier mais il ya d'autres
projets qui sont concernés celui du
grand besançon brest métropole océane
agglomération tourangelle bref il y à
une attente et je pense que cet article
devrait permettre d'avancer dans ce sens
alors je sais bien que le point de
départ ça a été le projet de
débranchement vers clichy montfermeil du
tramway aulnay bondy
mais c'est un projet parmi d'autres
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité faire référence à ses autres
projets et je crois que les autorités
organisatrices sont très demanderesse
d'un dispositif de ce genre qui leur
facilite les choses et qui permet
d'accéder la réalisation des projets
j'ai donc pas d'objection sur cet
article 17
y at il d'autres demandes de parole il
n'y en a pas je mets au voile article 17
qui est pour contre il est adopté
article 18 demandes de parole de
monsieur roland rice
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
1 l'article 18 prévoit la possibilité
pour un syndicat mixte compétent en
matière de transports publics d'adhérer
à un syndicat mixte de coordination
communément appelée syndicat mixe sru
cette possibilité est également offerte
aux établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale qui ont
transféré la compétence transports les
syndicats mixtes sru ont pour mission
première de permettre une coopération
entre les autorités organisatrices des
départements et les régions dans un
objectif de meilleure intégration des
systèmes il en matière de transports la
capacité de regrouper plusieurs
périmètres de transports urbains et
peuvent par exemple recouvrir l'ensemble
du périmètre départemental ou régional
en outre ils ont pour compétence
obligatoire de coordonner les services
organisés de mettre en place un système
d'information à l'intention des usagers
et de rechercher la création d'une
tarification coordonnées et les titres
de transport unique ou unifiée je ne
peux donc qu'admettre que les syndicats
mixtes sru dispose des moyens
nécessaires pour répondre aux enjeux de
cette intermodalité pour autant on peut
quand même s'interroger sur la
complexification que ce dispositif
apportera au monde des transports dans
les rares territoires où cette faculté
faculté pourra être utilisé la
compétence transport urbain et déjà
délégué par les a ôté ua des syndicats
mix classique qui pourrait ainsi
déléguer eux-mêmes une partie
d'incompétence au gré des compromis
locaux l'article 18 vient donc s'ajouter
encore aux délégations déjà possible
sauf à corriger à la marge statut de ce
syndicat mixe sru pour les limiter à des
fonctions de coordination et
d'information
il ya peut-être un risque de
démembrement de la compétence transport
dans les zones les plus urbanisées en ce
sens j'espère que le remède aujourd'hui
proposée ne sera pas pire que le mal
qu'il est supposé guérir
d'autant que ces syndicats mixtes de
coordination n'ont pas aujourd'hui le
succès escompté
probablement à cause des délégations en
cascade proposé ces dernières années les
législatives devraient peut-être alors
se poser la question de la nature même
du dispositif et syndicat mixe sru c'est
le message que je
voulait exprimer ici mais bien entendu
nous sommes favorables à cet article le
354 est présentée par monsieur raoult
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre c'est
cet amendement est un amende de deux
précisions sur un amendement qui avait
déjà été votée dans un autre texte et
qui se rapporte donc à ces allocations
de ces fameux syndicat mixte de
d'envergure régionale et auquel le
président et sénateurs percheron
tiennent énormément et pour ne pas
prendre ce texte un peu précaire
nous vous proposons de transformer
l'expression transport urbain en
transports publics par les mots
transports publics de telle manière que
on est bien dans ses syndicats mixtes
des organisations donc de transport
urbain et interurbain c'est à dire ceux
qui sont présidées par les géré par les
départements j'ai bien compris les les
quelques on va dire précaution que mon
collègue roland rice a exposé dans
précédemment mais je peux vous dire en
tous les cas que dans le nord pas de
calais il ya une volonté politique sens
noble du terme pour créer ce syndicat
mixte
je rappelle quand même que dans certains
secteurs vous avez du rural et durban le
même élève peut très bien prendre un car
qui lui sera financée par le département
ensuite monté à la garde en intra plus
ou moins géré par la région et arrivant
dans la ville centre de bois reprendre
un autre billet pour prendre le tramway
de valenciennes et or donc avec une
autre organisation ça veut dire que sur
le même trajet scolaire est bien le même
élève doit prendre trois tickets doit
s'organiser pour aller je dirais remplir
des dossiers et tout ça avec des tarifs
évidemment totalement différent et je
suis pas sûr que d'ailleurs le cas
venant du petit village pour aller
jusqu'à la gare permettent d'arriver à
l'heure pour prendre le train parce
qu'il n'arrivera que le trail passe deux
minutes avant et je passe sur les les
mille et une difficultés quand on voit
les les parents d'élèves à la rentrée
faire le tour de toutes ces structures
uns les unes après les autres
on est vraiment désespérée de la france
et la parole de mirabaud qui disait que
la france à la veille de la révolution
c'est un agrégat a constitué de peuples
désunis
mais j'ai le regret de dire que dans les
transports on en est encore là merci
monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission azam la présidente monsieur
le ministre
chers collègues je répondrais d'abord un
roland ries ce qu'il faut pas qu'ils
s'inquiètent autant de démembrement de
ses transports en commun au moment même
où dans le texte de loi que l'on
présente aujourd'hui vous avez la
possibilité pour les pays qui ont
transféré leurs compétences transports
d'adhérer à ces mêmes syndicats ce qui
montre bien la volonté justement d'unir
les forces de travailler en commun pour
arriver au résultat qui nous importe
tous donc dans l'amendement de monsieur
notre collègue percheron la raison
d'être des syndicats mixtes sru et de
coordonner effectivement l'offre de
service des autorités organisatrices de
transport sur un territoire
par conséquent s'il existe dans certains
départements des syndicats mixtes dédiée
au transport périurbain ou interurbains
qui souhaitent adhérer au syndicat mixe
sru il est légitime de remplacer
l'expression trop restrictive de
transport urbain par celles plus souple
de transport
or publique avis favorable de la
commission à vis du gouvernement
même la présidente et gouvernement est
naturellement très favorable à cet
amendement et je dirais même si raul
sans citer mirabeau que nous fêtons
cette semaine en charente maritime le
dixième anniversaire le 10e là syndicat
mixte comprenant la région le
département toutes les communautés
d'agglomération qui depuis dix ans a
créé un titre de pain de transport
unique qui s'appelle passe partout comme
le célèbre personnage de fort boyard et
que donc ce sont des politiques dont
nous voyons tous la légitimité et que
nous soutenons alors je mets au voile
l'amendement
pardonnez moi monsieur le ministre
monsieur fourcade merci madame la
présidente je voudrais poser une
question au ministre
je comprends très bien l'objet de
l'amendement qui consiste à éviter des
ruptures
dès qu'on sort du domaine urbain mais
lorsqu'une communauté d'agglomération ou
une commune importante pas son contrat
avec une entreprise privée pour faire du
transport à l'intérieur il ne faudrait
pas que la nouvelle appellation de
transport public soit une gêne pour
qu'elles puissent faire l'opération à
boulogne billancourt de mes
prédécesseurs a eu la sagesse de créer
un système de transport en intrants
communal
j'ai fait un appel d'offres et j'ai eu
et la ratp d'un côté et une entreprise
privée de l'autre il ne faudrait pas que
le fait de dire transports publics
interdisent une collectivité de passer
un accord avec une entreprise privée ce
qui est public c'est le caractère de
l'autorité qui concède le service soit
bien d'accord
pierre donc nous voterons d'amendements
très bien donc je mets aux voileux 354
qui est pour contre non il est adopté je
mets aux voix l'article 18 qui est pour
article 18
il est adopté à l'article 19
monsieur rice pour le groupe socialiste
et si madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
comment ne pas se réjouir de voir le
gouvernement reprendre les dispositions
essentielles la proposition de loi que
j'avais soumise à la haute assemblée le
11 mai 2006 et qui avait été voté
rappelons-nous à l'unanimité cette
proposition de loi était malheureusement
resté en instance et n'avait pas passé à
l'assemblée nationale elle va donc être
intégré pour l'essentiel dans notre
projet de loi j'aurais rappeler tout
d'abord que l'autopartage consiste pour
une société ou une association à mettre
une flotte d'automobiles à la
disposition d'abonnés ou de porteurs de
parts de la société pour le courte durée
n'excédant général pas les 24 à
distinguer donc du covoiturage notre
partage constituant qu'une forme
particulière de location et se
différencient nettement du covoiturage
qui consiste lui a regroupé pour un même
trajet des passagers dans une voiture
privatives donc de mieux remplir les
véhicules en circulation dans faire si
on veut des mini transports en commun
chacun sait que dans toute voiture en
circulation il ya en général 4 places
parfois davantage et que en moyenne
chaque voiture qui circule dans ce pays
à 1,2 personnes à bord donc en montant
simplement à 2 à 3 on a autant de
voitures en circulation en moins
l'autopartage quant à lui part du
constat du gaspillage de la ressource
automobile il a en effet été établi que
les automobiles sont utilisés en moyenne
en france pendant seulement 8% de leur
durée de vie
ce qui veut dire que pendant 92 % de
leur durée de vie elles ne servent à
rien et non seulement et ne servent à
rien mais l'encombrant l'espace elles
ont recours pour la voirie il faut les
leur construire des parkings des gares
âgées bref oui nommé
en réalité la statistique est là lui
pour cent du temps de vie est utile 92 %
du temps de vie est inutile entre
guillemets donc cette situation entraîne
gaspillage économique environ
environnemental et humain
le fait pour les consommateurs
d'immobiliser autres avenues arguments
leur capital dans une automobile qui
n'est utilisé que de façon très
marginale par rapport aux possibilités
techniques constitue à l'évidence une
allocation sous optimale des ressources
des ménages
en outre le consommateur peine à
calculer le coût de l'utilisation d'une
automobile
celui ci nous le savons tous ne se
résume en effet pas aux coûts immédiats
du carburant mais devrait prendre en
compte l'amortissement du véhicule sa
maintenance et le coût de son
stationnement
justement et de son assurance la sous
utilisation des automobiles conduit à
multiplier le nombre de véhicules par
rapport à ce que demanderait une
utilisation optimale ceux qui consomment
de façon inutile les matières premières
nécessaires à leur construction
en outre la multiplication du nombre de
véhicules entraîne nécessairement une
consommation accrue de carburant et une
pollution plus importante
en définitive la possession par un
consommateur d'une automobile incite à
utiliser ce mode de transport dans des
situations où d'autres modes serait plus
performant sur le plan de l'intérêt
général
transports en commun taxis déplacements
à pied à vélo etc
la multiplication du nombre de voitures
particulières qui pour l'essentiel leur
durée de vie sont immobilisés en
stationnement est très consommatrice
d'espacé ce qui conduit à dégrader la
qualité de l'environnement urbain il va
presque sans dire que cette perte d'
espaces se fait également au détriment
des autres modes de transport de surface
en ce sens vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues la logique de
l'autopartage est donc de réserver à
l'automobile les seuls déplacements pour
lesquelles ce mode de transport est le
plus adapté le plus pertinent
cette activité nasa d'un script à en
concurrence des autres modes de
transport l'autopartage aboutit au
contraire à les renforcer
en effet le développement de
l'autopartage permet de limiter l'usagé
de l'automobile en propriété directe au
seul trajet pour les
quelle elle constitue le mode de
transport le plus adéquat
le recours aux autres modes de transport
transport en commun taxis circulation
douce pour les trajets quotidiens et
location de véhicule pour les
déplacements s'étendant sur plus d'une
journée étant parallèlement accru de ce
fait l'autopartage et portant
d'économies pour le consommateur et de
gains multiples pour la collectivité
ce plan environnemental et permet une
réduction de la pollution automobile
ce plan des déplacements urbains ils
contribuent à une amélioration
la fluidité des circulations sur la
voirie enfin la réduction du nombre
nécessaire d'automobiles permet une
diminution de l'espace urbain consacré
au stationnement et donc la reconquête
d'une qualité urbaine que l'omniprésence
automobile avait des thériault alors que
les premières expériences françaises
d'autopartage remonte aux années 70
notre pays a par la suite accumulé un
retard important dans ce domaine
en comparaissant tout du moins du
développement important de cette
activité dans de nombreux pays européens
aujourd'hui des expériences
d'autopartage existe dans plusieurs
grandes villes françaises en particulier
à paris et strasbourg mais aussi dans
d'autres villes en reprenant l'essentiel
cas du sommaire je ne sais pas en
reprenant l'essentiel de ma proposition
de loi je constate avec satisfaction que
le gouvernement entend remédier à cet
ordre des choses peu satisfaisants et à
faire rattraper à notre pays
des pays comme les pays bas l'allemagne
la suisse ou l'autopartage est nettement
plus développé que chez nous j'aurai
l'occasion tout à l'heure le proposer un
amendement à ce à cet article merci
alors nous arrivons en effet à
l'amendement numéro 55 rectifié qui le
présente monsieur rice
je suis désolé de faire un one man show
mais je ne voudrais pas lasser mais mes
collègues et tout à l'heure d'autres
biens alors il s'agit d'un amendement un
qui devrait permettre de clarifier la
question de l'attribution du label
autopartage le label autopartage est
très important parce qu'il permet de
distinguer l'activité auto partage d'une
activité de location classique